Parisian Couture could influence how
thousands of ordinary women dream and
live but fashion needs a new
leader now Figure
Head
[Applause]
I keep looking for the great collection
to Rise From the Ashes of
[Music]
the what do you desire to design the
most beautiful women's clothing that
ever existed
look ruin French cout and I'm coming
back to say
it for those of us who lived through the
chaos of War
creation was
Survivor The Legend of Coco Chanel if
people only
[Music]
you have to come and arrest me SEL can
be very treacherous oh
yes are you happy with the revolution
you
started there is the truth my mind is
but there is always another truth that
lives behind it yes
she's not safe creation cannot stop the
bullets but creation is our way
forward our choices matter I
am
arm use my
legs use my
head use my heart your house will be
magnificent you think speci I will
real talent is turning your life into
something
[Music]
bigger people need to fear dream they
need to live again we can create a new
world for
[Music]
them